you were gracious enough to come in with
the guys today because we thought it
would be a cool thing to remember people
who passed away recently Christine McVey
from Fleetwood mag she is one of the
most beautiful vocalists and piano
players in the world uh Christine and um
the song we're doing today I'm really
glad that y'all let me do it because
this was the song my mom walked down the
aisle to song bird mhm you knew this
song as a little girl you knew I haven't
told her that I'm performing it today so
she's going to be she's going to lose
her have you ever performed this
before for her no I've never sung this
before today oh really well I mean we
I've sung it in my car for like decades
yeah this is my first time performing it
the song what the hell is song bird
about to you I just think of my son um
because it obviously has this
somber quality to the the take because
it's a one take recording but I think I
think my favorite thing when I was kind
of looking at why she wrote this or how
she wrote this was that it wasn't about
anyone in particular she was like it's
about nobody and everybody and those are
the best songs are just they're
Universal they don't have to be specific
it just makes you feel something so
deeply emotional and yeah I don't know
it was it was like my son was the the
image that popped into my head when I
was um relearning this um but you know
so many people have had weddings to this
song funerals dog funerals um so it's
just one of those songs that applies to
all
situations yeah it's it's a great song
and we're going to get in the mood and
we're going to remember Christine McVey
who passed away here we
[Music]
go for
you there be no more
[Music]
cry for
you the sun will be
[Music]
shine and I feel that when I'm with
you it's all right
I know it's
[Music]
right to
you I give the
world to
you I never
[Music]
be cuz I feel that when I'm with
you it's all
right I know it's
right and the song
bird are singing that they know the
go and I love you I love you I love
you like never
[Music]
before
and I wish you all the
love in the
world
oh but most of
all I wish it from
myself and the song long
birds are singing like they know the
[Music]
skar and I love you I love you I love
you like never
before like never
before like
never
before
[Music]